the songbird silence a nearly true story
[Laughter]
not that long ago there was a forest
where you could hear the birds singing
the Tigers growl in Far Away and the
insects trade then human beings began to
capture the creatures of the forest the
creature they wanted most was a songbird
because it's song was so beautiful there
was a little boy called dooba who loved
listening to the mysterious noises of
the forest as he went to sleep at night
he imagined the turtles tell him one
another stories the birds in singing
competitions
the Tigers talked him to the moon this
helped him sleep well at night on dubas
birthday his parents gave him a songbird
it came in a big cage he was grateful
for it he'd never had a pet before he
grew very attached to the songbird he
was only really happy when it was
singing but sometimes when the bird
signed he was so moved that he would
start crying and because of this
dooba wanted to know what he was singing
about he asked everyone he met if they
knew his parents didn't know the eldest
couldn't tell him either then one day he
met a wise old woman oh wise woman do
you know what the songbird is saying he
asked that songbird is wiser than me
said the wise woman why do you say that
because it's song made you ask many
questions how can I find out what it's
saying since that bird is wiser than me
you should ask it how I taught speak his
language I won't understand what it says
how do you know I've tried ask the
question in a different way
how you'll know when the time comes I
hope so you should listen in a different
way to how should I do that you should
listen with more than your years what
else should I listen with them if not my
ears perhaps said there's a woman you
should listen with your heart
when Du Bois got home he forgot to
listen to the birdsong because he was
thinking about how he could listen with
his heart that night tossing and turning
he slept very badly he was aware that
something that made his sleep lovely was
missing he fell asleep just before dawn
and he had a dream in his dream the
songbird spoke to him do you want to
know why my song is so beautiful yes do
you want to know what I'm singing about
yes no one could tell me I'm the only
one who can tell you but you had to ask
the right question you had to listen
with your heart
did I ask the right question yes how you
asked it with your soul you asked it
from the part of you that really cared
but what's the answer
have you noticed anything different
about the world
no what what's different have you
noticed that something is missing yes
but I don't know what it is no one does
what is it
the forest is silent is it why because
people have been treating the animals
and birds badly do they yes take me for
example
do you think I'm happy you must be your
songs are so beautiful that's because
I'm unhappy my songs are telling of the
terrible things people are doing to the
forest to pangalanes the beautiful birds
the Tigers because people are not
protecting them the forest is silent
really yes the forest is dying what can
I do listen with your heart I like
having you as a pet I know but I don't
like being a pet I'm made to be free my
song is beautiful in your cage but you
should hear me sing when I am free
what's it like then it's as if all
nature is singing the sea the sky the
trees the majestic creatures is as if
God is singing through me my song when
I'm free is a million times richer than
my song in a cage the only song I sing
in a cage is a song of tears the song of
the
silent forest I'm so sorry if you're
really sorry you do something for me
what's that
wake up Dubai woke up suddenly it was
still dark
he listened it was true the forest was
still on silent he didn't hear the
Tigers or the insect noises he went to
the cage the songbird was silent nothing
he did would make the songbird sing then
he realized that the songbird would not
sing anymore he woke up his mother and
father they were surprised that he was
waking him up mum and dad he said we
have done the songbird a terrible wrong
we have taken it from his home in the
forest and now it will not sing because
of the songbird the forest is silent
have you not noticed his mother and
father listened you're right they said
the forest is silent how is it we never
noticed we have to help her forest live
again said the boy first we must
carefully return the songbird to its
home then we must protect the creatures
of the world or one day we too will fall
silent how do you know these things
master father I just started to listen
he said with my heart
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]